[Music]
from shirts to footballs and almost
everything in between World Cup
merchandise is a big business from small
items costing four dollars to elaborate
limited edition pieces costing thousands
the range has something that will appeal
to every fan
[Music]
to take in consideration that not
everyone can afford high-end products
and even with the pricing we were very
careful that we priced uh you know
according to the budgets of almost
everyone and make sure that you know
nobody was will be left left without
without taking back something with them
home for many World Cup fans the
souvenirs thereby will be part of their
lasting memories of the tournament but
what's available and what it looks like
even the patterns and the colors are
carefully considered
[Music]
we've done the schmar in gutra and in
the colors of the teams and we actually
dyed them exactly to The Penton color of
that country it took us like maybe a
year to make to get this right so we
wanted people to take back not only
World Cup but they take back Qatar with
them
some of the best-selling items are in
the collection of China they were
created by a local designer who's hoping
this will be her big break it is a huge
responsibility and it's a big
opportunity that I got as I will be
showing parts of Qatar
part of the taste of Qatar how we are
expressing the design and art into the
pieces that they will use every day
established designers have also been on
a World Cup Journey prakash maroli
started work on this project three years
ago and has created a range with a
traditional Qatari cultural feel the
design phase itself took six months with
many religions and approvals from from
FIFA to the top Management in Qatar and
we try to create a cultural range which
is actually a legacy merchandise because
all this merchandise will be used and
will be shared after the World Cup also
[Music]
beautiful and vibrant World Cup
and that sentiment is reflected in all
the items fans will take away from the
tournament San hamosh Al Jazeera Doha